well about 18 years ago we started a
not-for-profit called first which is an
acronym for inspiration and recognition
of Science and Technology the theory at
the time and even more so today was that
despite popular opinion to the contrary
most kids really are scientists they
really love to discover new things check
their theories out poke at the world see
what happens but we have a society that
does a couple of things that I think are
constantly gnawing away at kids
perspective on science and technology
number one we have created in this media
driven culture of ours an obsession with
two places from which we create all the
role models the world of sports and the
world of entertainment the NBA the NFL
and Hollywood are where all the role
models seem to come from on television
billboards newspapers magazines non-stop
second thing we do is we turn science
and engineering from a curiosity based
activity to something that gets judged
something that gets measured kids are
intimidated by the way science and
technology is presented it's made
frankly quite boring and it becomes part
of a curriculum that chases particularly
women and minority away so 18 years ago
we decided that while other people
interested in the problem of how we
going to get more kids in our pipeline
how are we going to stimulate the next
generation of scientists and engineers
and those other people whether they're
governments teachers not-for-profits
foundations all focused and to this day
focus on things on the supply side of
the education crisis they all want more
teachers more standards more books what
tests more you name it we said
let's take the contrarian view that the
reason so few kids are doing well on
math and science or even choosing to
study at all in this country is not in
fact an education crisis and it's not
about a limitation on supply we took the
contrarian position that science and
technology simply aren't presented as
being fun and exciting we took the
position it's not a supply problem at
all it's a demand problem or lack of it
among kids and we took the position it's
not an education problem it's a culture
problem in the culture of America and a
free culture you get what you celebrate
and in this culture we have to obsession
become a group that celebrates sports
heroes and entertainment heroes there's
no room left for kids to see even a
little bit of the opportunities to
really really get excited about becoming
an inventor an engineer a scientist a
problem solver so we formed an
organization for inspiration and
recognition of Science and Technology
notice the name it it's not for profit
doesn't have the word education in it
we're not an education foundation we are
for inspiring kids and having them
recognize science and technology really
are accessible they really are fun they
really are rewarding and they really are
the places where career opportunities
abound most kids today that will dribble
a ball hour after hour dreaming of being
the next Shaquille O'Neal most of these
kids have virtually no chance of ever
making a career in professional sports
but any kid that's willing to spend any
reasonable number of hours a day or even
per week studying math studying physics
studying engineering studying science
can have literally an unbounded set of
opportunities for careers in science and
technology but they don't know it and
our culture works on it preventing them
from knowing either how much fun it is
how rewarding it is how accessible is
going to be so first is about changing
kids perspective particularly women in
our
and frankly changing the perspective of
our society and our culture about what's
important